Don't come close to me
[Music] Has
Rokudosuke finally shown his true nature?
[Music] I'll take
3 minutes per person. If it were me, I would
defeat him in 1 minute.
Actually, it would take 30 seconds. As expected, I'm number one in the Onijima Alliance. I'll
never let you show me your openings.  Well, if
you're the one, you'll be able to
tell the difference in each other's strength even if we don't fight.The
stronger the opponent is, the more it burns, the more it has the
opposite effect.The stronger I show myself, the more
wonderful it has been since I was born.It's fallen into such tatters.Everything is
perfect, and I'm so close.  That's how cute you are as a
human being.
That's
what's wrong. The
window opened and it was
dangerous. Why did you save me? I was about to
fall in. What's this? It's natural for you to
help me. Even though you were being
bullied so much by me, you could have
easily saved me.  I should be able to crush you, but what is
this feeling? My
heart is tighter than ever. What
should I do? Rokudou-kun is growing stronger inside me.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music] What is
this?